building companies is a is is is a
an ongoing fixing slash optimization
process you're constantly running into
things that either you think are
completely broken and you're trying to
fix or you're looking at them and you
say we can do a lot better they're less
optimized so that that's that's really
what you know um uh what your role is as
as as ceo he's trying to identify those
types of of things and trying to you
know provide directors and guidance and
and and you know when it's you we need
to roll up your sleeves and and do some
of the work yourself that's absolutely
something you need to do as well
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lomitek and
sponsored by homework ventures hippo
insurance opwest hillel stanford leap
and birthright excel welcome to another
episode of 20 minute leaders meet mark
gaffin ceo of isolate
mark is a successful ceo entrepreneur
and cyber security veteran prior to
joining heist lake mark was the chief
business officer at nexar and an
executive in residence at bessemer
venture partners
in 2009 gaffin co-founded encapsula and
after its acquisition by imperva led the
encapsulate business as ceo to 100
million dollars in run rate protecting
millions of websites worldwide and many
of the world's largest enterprises in
telcos
mark is a thought leader and has
appeared before the us congress fdic and
federal trade commission on cyber
security and identity theft topics
he holds an mba in bsc in computer
science and economics from talvi
university
mark gaffin welcome to 20 minute leaders
how are you today
i'm well michael great to be here
thank you very much for being here a
leader in the cyber world i'm really
excited for these next 20 minutes uh
just like with a lot of episodes i know
a little bit about where we're gonna
start but i have no idea where we're
going to end your career is so
fascinating today you're the ceo of
isolate but if i just begin to list the
different things that you've been a part
of and most importantly of course
working at zapper 20 years ago i i
completely filled my heart with that one
before we started but
you know very quick shortly uh you know
board member of a few amazing companies
chief business officer of nexar before a
company that i love
you are executive in residence in
bessemer venture partners
you were the ceo and co-founder of
encapsula which was acquired by imperva
and michelle lipscore from imperva was
also on this show and so
before the director of product marketing
of rsa security and a bunch more things
that i'm not even going to go into right
now
first i want to start off grand mark
what what is how do you describe your
career if you had to think about you
know what your journey is like
what are some thoughts that come to mind
because you've done so much and you've
worn so many hats
you know i i like to describe my career
as i started off as as a techie
and you know over the years moved into
product and business hats um i'm
actually a big believer of that that
journey especially in the in the
high-tech world i think that that in
order to
um to lead you've got to have a sound
technical or product at least uh
appetite uh and i'm i'm you know if you
look at a a career that i would try and
plan that's those that come with some of
the the the milestones i would look to
build into a master plan
i love it i love it okay so
what i'd love to understand a little bit
from your perspective is
where we're at right now specifically
perhaps in israel or the cyber world and
the different trends that you know
perhaps looking at the last
dozen or so years and what's been
happening or two dozen years and what's
been happening and then i'd like to also
transition a little bit to what you're
doing today with isolate and more in the
context of leadership and cyberspace and
what does it mean to be a leader in this
domain so take me tell me a little bit
about the cyberspace in general and what
you've observed has changed within the
cyberspace in israel
i've been in the cyber space since 2005
my first cyber security company was a
company called sciota that became part
of rsa
most of people don't know that name they
call it naftali bennett's company but um
essentially you know my cyber career had
started about 16 years ago
um
and
i would say that the as technology is
accelerating so the cyber uh
requirements or the the the uh the
threats
essentially have become um you know even
more severe
and i think like
everyone else over the last 18 or 19
months since curve is broke the
acceleration or the digital
transformation that we're going
uh through the entire world
is going to accelerate the need for
cyber you know for additional cyber
security measures there's new threats
that are being introduced there's new
formats of work with the remote work
work from anywhere hybrid work uh these
are all things this is a massive change
in paradigm you know there's those that
will say that we've leapfrogged 10 years
in you know in 18 months in terms of
progression
when you have something like this such a
tightened title wave that's um that's
taking place there's lots of uh of lots
of ways to try and address them and that
that creates a
great foundation for innovation
i think i i love that and you know if
you're looking now at this this idea of
innovation and you're looking at the
cyberspace what what have you found
helpful as you're navigating through
thinking about these threats and about
where innovation is going to take place
in this cat and mouse game what what has
sort of been sort of your north star in
thinking through what are the next big
things that i should be working on
because you've worked on so many
different things
so it's a good point that it very much
aligns with what we're doing at isolates
the you know the the title shift from a
from an i.t perspective
is the fact that
so many people are working remotely if
you know if two years ago
um most organizations and most
enterprises
assume that 80 or 90 of people were
going to be within the corporate
firewall 80 to 90 percent of the time
that's how they built their uh their
threat their threat models and that's
how they built their their you know
their security strategies
um that all changed so all of a sudden
we went to almost a hundred percent of
the people or a hundred percent of the
time um you know outside of the firewall
now that means that we are
using our home networks way way more
than we've used than before that means
that we're using our personal devices um
more than we've used them before for
corporate stuff we're giving our kids
often um the opportunity or not the
opportunity but we need to render our
corporate devices to to you know to
members of our family our corporate
advisors sitting on our kitchen tables
because we're you know we're working
from home
and um i think that everyone's come to
the realization
that that's going to stay to some extent
okay we're not going to go all the way
back to the office and we're not going
to stay at home 100 of the time
we're going to be you know some type of
an accordion essentially of of of this
you know the hybrid work but what that
means really from and if you're planning
if you're an i.t guy if you're a
security guy and you're planning your
strategy you really have to address both
extreme situations today or you know a
situation where everyone could be
working from home because i think no
one's going to say never again about a
pandemic because we've been you know
we've been burned and we're also seeing
that once you know even throughout this
pandemic when we've uh uh ruled victory
we've seen that things are not so uh
we're we actually aren't so victorious
and we're kind of back to square one so
this whole notion of of having to enable
work from everywhere is a new um
theme or a new axiom that we need to
take into consideration where as we
build our ipn security strategies
so i want to i want to
you know dwell on this point for just a
couple more minutes because i think it's
fascinating and it's something that we
all need to stop and think about because
when i look back at some of the most
incredible innovations in the cyberspace
at least in the israeli scene let's say
checkpoint for example you know we're
thinking about these firewalls we're
thinking about these protection systems
on-prem you know within organizations
that are going to help us
be isolated within our organizations so
what
what's happening now and where do you
think we're going to be seeing a lot of
the cyber shift as we're transitioning
now to you know working remotely and
accepting that as a new reality
especially in a world where we're also
accepting that for example ppi and
sensitive data is being used by a lot of
people and a lot of employees on a lot
of devices
so first of all i think we all need to
recognize the fact that data is a new
gold or data is the new diamonds or data
is a new oil call it whatever you want
but data is the new
um
i would call it non-natural resource
that is super super highly priced and
highly valued and the same way it's
valued by corporations and what we can
do with the data
that's how value it is by the cyber
criminals they realize that getting
their hands on the data has a huge
amount of potential it's become a high
priced
commodity essentially so everyone's
after you know the data essentially and
all cyber attacks are essentially out to
typically get data you do get scenarios
which is it's totally um financial
around ransomware we're not trying to
steal your data we're just trying to
extort right mostly people want to steal
data or either to extort you or to use
that data to extort others um there's
always a financial incentive behind it
unless it's it's it's you know nation
state or or or espionage which is you
know a big part of the the the cyber
security space but i would say that you
know b2b b2c
is where most of us are focused and
that's where most of our concerns are
specifically around our own privacy
um so assuming that data's the the
center of gravity it's all about
protecting the data and it's about
protecting access to data because we
need to give different people in the
organizations and different systems
access to you know to data the question
is how do we do this uh securely and
it's not you know now that there's no
perimeter and where all of us are
outside of the firewall um our laptops
essentially have become our new offices
so that's that's the new you know that's
the new office for us so that's the new
parameter which essentially means that
there's no perimeter and the question is
how do we give people the flexibility to
um
a do what they need to do on their
laptop so that they can be productive
that they can browse the web and they
can communicate and they can collaborate
but also how can they touch corporate
systems and data which are most likely
sensitive
without jeopardizing corporate security
right so effective leadership and in
cyberspace you know you're coming in
with your own background and your
understanding of what's happening here
and you know effectively you've managed
to be a very successful executive in a
variety of companies and so that's not
by chance what does it mean to be an
effective leader in your eyes
specifically in the cyber domain whether
it's in the interpersonal part in the
visionary part and what how are you
bringing that into isolate right now
you know i don't think that the cyber
security space is different from a
leadership from a reader from a
leadership role than than than any other
space i just happen to find myself spend
you know um a lot of time in the space
become a
um i won't i won't say i'm an expert but
as far as i'm concerned i'm you know
that's an area that i can that i can be
most uh most effective in because of you
know the the the experience
um i think at the end of the day it's
very much about the people that you um
that you have on your team it's about
building you know strong teams you're
not going to do this journey alone
building a company is something that's
uh it's it's a marathon
um it doesn't take you know typically a
year or two or three it takes a lot more
than that
you need the right people around you the
ability to execute with the right team
is going to be
key and i think it's all about you know
how do you bring the right people on
board how do you empower them how do you
give them the ability to
on the one hand execute but on the other
hand and have you know latitude but on
the other hand stay focused and all stay
uh stay aligned
um often there's conflicting interest
and there's conflicting priorities it's
how do you keep everyone aligned and
keep you know keeping everyone on the
same page but um you know and doing that
effectively
and i think that an important question
though that needs to be asked is also
why start another company you've you've
started companies you've been an
executive in existing companies you've
been in the venture capital world why
start another company at this point
so i didn't actually start isolate i
joined isolate two years ago as a ceo
more of a you can call it a professional
ceo as someone who's been in this role
before
so i didn't start isolate but i decided
to join a very early stage company which
is
i i you know with all due respect it's
way closer to the beginning of the
journey than to the end of the journey
um
it's it's a part of the journey that i
enjoy it's about figuring out you know
what customers want what customers need
trying to find out you know how we can
um with the building blocks that we have
how can we address this in the most
effective way
um
it was you know it was also about
meeting the right people so the you know
meeting my you know my partner at high
stall who was the founder of the company
and the ceo before me and you know we
saw that we could forge a really good
partnership in wichita
you know owns the technical and product
side um
and i you know i can focus more on the
the the business and growing the company
so you know we found that to be
in not by starting a company but as we
you know as we got to know each other
and as we um
we got to formulate the idea of me
coming in
um
it sounded like the right you know food
from us
um
i also you know know a lot of the
investors on the team and i've had
relationships with them in the past you
know whether it's bessemer or the the um
the partners on at teammate which i've
had interactions with in the past so at
the end of the day you know the the the
partners that you that you join the the
founders the management team the
investors um a big part of the uh the
decision is are you joining a you know a
group of people that you um that you
want to work with in addition to the
idea and the potential in the market
it's a lot easier by the way to pervert
the product sometimes even to private
the entire market
but uh switching out the team and
investors and founders is a lot harder
um you know early stage companies as you
know if i put my investor or my angel
investor out here on you know for a
second it's really about the team uh
again you can change ideas you can
change directions it's very difficult to
change the team or the impact of
changing the team is significant so you
know that's uh that's why i decided to
to to join isolate
and so what what steps did you take to
make it as smooth of a transition as
possible no matter what a changing
leadership or adding to a leadership to
an existing company
um you know it's it's not a trivial
process and
i'm really curious as to what you know
with your experience what did you do
as he transitioned into this role that
you felt either helped or or didn't help
make this process a smooth one not just
for you but also for a lot of the
employees that were already in the
company and for the the all the
different stakeholders that were
involved
right so i think that you know the most
important thing
to do and this is something that i try
to do as much as possible is to spend
the first few months and really learning
um learning i would say the 360
of you know what the company which means
talking to customers understanding you
know or talking to prospects and
customers understanding what's you know
how we're solving their problem
um to what you know to what extent we
can solve their problems uh
understanding uh and talking to all the
employees in the company understanding
you know what's driving them are they in
a good place uh are our teams built
effectively are we executing and doing
that you know um top down so
talking to all the executives talking to
you all the managers talking to all the
employees understanding you know
where we can where we can try and
optimize
um and then trying to piece things
together from an execution perspective
to see you know how are we executing
building kpis understanding what are the
most important things to do trying you
know there's always
in any in any business and and this is
not just a new business that you join
there's always there's always things to
fix um companies are a you know all
building companies is a is
is a
an ongoing fixing slash optimization
process you're constantly running into
things that either you think are
completely broken and you're trying to
fix or you're looking at them and you
say we can do a lot better they're less
optimized so that that's that's really
what you know um uh what your role is as
as as ceo he's trying to identify those
types of of things and trying to you
know provide directors and guidance and
and you know when it's you we need to
roll up your sleeves and and do some of
the work yourself that's absolutely
something you need to do as well but
that's really what you know what ceos uh
should be doing and that's that's you
know those are the things that i did for
the first few months
you know until we built a new strategy
um a big tidal wave hit us you know as
we were formulating you know our
strategy which was covered and you know
one of the changes that we made um were
driven by the fact that we anticipated
that covert would change the workforce
landscape and we decided to you know to
address that with you know with with um
with the product portfolio not the
product portfolio but the product
building blocks that we had
we re-architected a product we built a
product that would be you know um
very very effective in a remote
work type of you know scenario
that's that's the new isolate for the
last you know
14 15 months since we made some of the
changes we think that the world's
changed and
you know i'm i always say that
building a startup is like is like
surfing
you you know you get on your board you
paddle out into the water and you look
for a wave
um and if the wave comes in you can ride
it great if the weight passes you
don't try and catch that wave look back
for other waves startups need to ride
waves it's really difficult google can
create a wave facebook can create a wave
regulatory uh uh you know regulators can
create waves a single company it's
really difficult for a single company to
create a wave if at all startups are
about riding the wave and and you know
disrupting existing waves um that's kind
of my i've never by the way ever gotten
on a surfboard um i grew up uh five
minutes five minutes from the beach and
i you know i i was i was never a surfer
all my friends were surfers but not me
no i'm laughing because i love this
analogy i picked up surfing in the last
couple months and you know when i'm
there and i'm and i'm waiting for that
wave and i'm seeing people try to paddle
like crazy because they're they're about
to miss the wave
most of the time they miss it and what
they don't realize is that if they were
to just wait for a few more seconds and
to look back and breathe then they would
have time to prepare for this next wave
that's about to come and sometimes it
takes minutes sometimes it takes seconds
but but it's all about that that perfect
timing and having that conviction and
doing it you know doing it calmly and
with a lot of purpose and so i love that
i love that analogy
thank you mark take me back to your
childhood
before cyber before zapper before sayoda
where who is mark you know that what
what really fascinates you where what
sparks your curiosity you know in
elementary school in middle school
i spent most of my my middle school in
high school
i actually didn't go to middle school by
the way i had we we didn't have middle
school where i granted we grew up we had
we had priests we had we had school and
we had uh you know a high school but i
spent i i spent most of my schooling
years on a tennis court
um
i i was infatuated with tennis i played
tennis oh i trained you know four or
five times a week i played tournaments i
went abroad um it was it was really you
know the biggest part of my childhood
was you know was on the tennis court
um
so my you know
great i did fine i did okay at school um
i liked
i like maths i like physics i did you
know those were my majors in in uh um in
high school i had a really easy path
with the english um being you know being
born abroad and growing up in an
english-speaking house things
were easy from an english perspective so
i didn't need to spend a lot of time um
getting a's for my english tests um so
that's kind of uh fantastic
you know
i love it
i i love it and if we had a few more
minutes i would definitely i would i
would be so happy to go into a
conversation about tennis and why that
is such a mentally rigorous game and and
one of the most incredible sports ever
as a tennis player myself i can
definitely relate if you were to look
today at what inspires you either on a
personal level or on a professional
level in the day to day when you wake up
when you when you do what you do
where do you gather your personal
inspiration
big or small
but you know when i look at
um at people i think that the people
that give me the most inspiration who
actually are people that have set
ambitious goals and have achieved them
and it could and it can really be across
multiple fronts it's you know um
it could be
building a business
and when i say building a business it
could be building a successful lemonade
stand which is not easy in a competitive
environment or building a massive you
know high-tech company um
even building you know a hamburger place
is is again far away from the the tech
space it's so difficult to build a
successful business today the
competitive landscapes the ability to
invent something new or to come up with
a you know with a a a a new concept and
to you know um craft your way into you
know into the market make it successful
those are the things when i when i you
know when i look at people that have
really achieved um those types of kind
of builders i would say builders really
get me
excited
i love it okay mark last question
what if you had to choose a few words
that you were to describe yourself
or if i would ask any of your partners
previous co-founders employees
who who is mark what words come to mind
when i think of mark what what would a
few of those words be
um so in no you know order of uh of
importance i would say um competitive
um
yes i'm super competitive i don't know
if i
uh love to win or hate to lose more it's
you know um i think there's
being being competitive is as has got
two components to it
um
my family is super important to me and i
would you know articulate myself as a
family person um my wife my three kids
um
you know definitely play a big role
we've we've we've we've traveled the
world uh as a family um for the last 15
years we've lived in lots of different
locations uh typically because of my
work
and that's kind of brought us together
as as a family very very uh nicely
um and you know my third i would say i'm
super patriotic um
i you know there's
i i often tell people that i i made
aliyah for those people that don't speak
hebrew rasai i immigrated to israel
three times
um once as a kid i had very i have i had
very little to say about it my parents
uh kind of slept me here at you know at
an early age their goal was to you know
build a build a home and a family in in
you know in israel um and twice after
that we moved to the us and you know for
extended periods and we decided to you
know to move back israel's a big part of
of my identity i'm super patriotic um
super keen and and bullish about the the
the tech scene here in general uh so i
would say that those are kind of the
things that uh that that i'm passionate
about or that uh that define me as and
and you know my beliefs
mark thank you very very much todahaba
this was wonderful
i cannot wait to share this with
everybody and thank you for the time and
the inspiration i can't wait to follow
your work with isolate and stay safe and
stay healthy thank you
excellent and just fyi
uh moshe lipsco
from imperva yeah
he was my commanding officer in the in
the in the out in the in the army so he
was magnificent
excellent um
small world uh we we are super super
super tight we've known each other for
30 years
incredible amazing amazing thank you
very very much for a great episode mark